[Musique]
bon déjà comme il faut que tu saches que
maman et moi on t'aime à une époque
maman et moi on partage un appartement
avec aurélien un jour m'a moins grosses
lèvres et là on voit l'utiliser au
milieu du ca montreuil pleurer et aucune
trace de rien on n'a jamais eu de ses
nouvelles
et donc le petit bébé c'est toi tu
manques dans l'ère aulas la merde mais
[ __ ] avant tout gober tout c'est qu'on
sent que c'est quand même hyper
spéciales comme ça et je rigole
nzita
[Musique]
aller en prison
ces départs
chez nos débuts
n'est ce pas
il va
c'est la pire des cas
martin
méfie-toi de leurs mérites et les gens
normaux ça la seule chose
et à
[Musique]
non
ils sont vraiment